welcome back to las vegas now the las
vegas metropolitan police department
foundation is gearing up to host a very
special event and special thank you to
the lvm pd foundation for sponsoring
today's segment on november 5th the 8th
annual best of the badge gala will take
place and here to tell us more about it
is sergeant miguel
miguel garcia excuse me alongside
detective juan contreras who's one of
this year's honorees thank you guys so
much for being here and congratulations
to you thank you so sergeant i'll start
with you let's just talk a little bit
about the event and just why it's so
important for the community well good
afternoon thank you for having me and
well it's important for the community
because this is the way for us to honor
our officers with the heroic actions
that they're taking throughout the year
and and it's a way for us to recognize
the hard work that they do and it's also
an opportunity for us to
show the community uh how appreciative
we are with all their help
and this event has been going on now
this is the eighth year of it what can
people expect talk me through the night
when people come through the doors of
the beautiful wind casino
well yes the event is a beautiful event
uh there is a silent auction to start
off the night uh during the cocktail
hour and uh eventually we get to uh to a
dinner and the most important part of
the night is when we start honoring the
officers for the incidents that they're
being honored for and detective you are
one of the honorees and congratulations
again how does it feel to be an honoree
and just represent the community well
thank you thank you very much uh it
feels great i'm uh i'm proud i'm proud
to be honored this way
and more so i'm just i'm grateful that i
was able to to be there for the citizen
on the day of the event more so than
anything
and the foundation supports metro and
all that you do so just talk about the
importance of people supporting this and
and where that money and everything
really goes well the beauty of the lbmp
foundation is the nonprofit is that
they're there to support us um in uh
supporting us with the programs that we
have specifically with the community we
talk about how we like to be engaged
with the community have that
relationship with everyone that lives in
our valley and this is one way that we
do that the foundation does a lot of
programs not just the the gala itself
but also like santa cops or turkey
drives that's coming up here pretty soon
those are the things that they help us
in helping with the community yeah a lot
of ways to support the lvmpd foundation
throughout the year and at this gala
there will be a lot of special honors
and recognitions including one for shea
micollonis can you tell us a little bit
about that
well yes
as we know shimmy clones was injured in
line of duty and he
suffered a life altering injury and it's
important for us to recognize that
sacrifice that he did and the community
really came together when this incident
happened and it really shows the support
and the those relationships that we have
with them and it really shows the
importance for us to honor the officers
absolutely and i know the community will
be interested in coming to support and
honoring so is this open to the public
and where can people get tickets
yes we ask them they can still go on to
the lvmpd foundation and click on their
uh the gala
tab there and they'll be able to get
more information on how to acquire
tickets for the show well thank you so
much you guys and for everything you do
to keep us safe in our community and for
more information it's all up there on
your screen the best of the badge gala
is happening on november 5th at the wynn
you can get your tickets now starting at
5 pm be sure to come out and honor and
support our everyday heroes we'll be
right back
[Music]